how do women how do met you said women
or men need women more than women need
men yeah how is that true when they want
everything that in society what do you
mean everything the power supply the
entire infrastructure of society oh it's
it's very simple it's because
construction needs sex more than women
need sex but can I just say that's all
you offer oh who offers
okay not all I offer because I I mean
you just said you just said you would do
nothing for a guy so when you don't have
to it's like when when you say that
that's not all you offer generally
speaking the things that you believe you
offer a man we point blank don't give a
[__] about yeah you can offer
personality you can offer the ability to
clean the house unless you're loyal and
that's good we genuinely don't give